Ça va franchement là je te jure j'en ai marre, j'en peux plus quoi.
Puis c'est toujours la même chose, au début c'est dingue, et après dès que ça redescend un peu les mecs me virent comme une merde.
Attends, ben là je me suis bien fait baisé j'vais te dire, au sens propre comme au sens figuré d'ailleurs.
Et salement en plus.
Salement comme celle ville qui me dégoute maintenant.
Paris, capitale de l'Amour, ouais c'est ça.
Tout le monde se fout de moi.
Attends excuse-moi, j'ai un double appel.
Ah la vache c'est lui qui me rapelle !
Allo ?
Je suis intolérant au gluten.
Ça veut dire pas de pâtes pas de pizzas, tu veux que je crève ou quoi ?
Mais qu'est-ce que t'es chiant !
Quoi ?
Mais quand il s'agit de te bourrer la gueule au houblon Julien,
mais là y a du monde hein ?
Tu te rends compte quand même,
ça fait 5 ans qu'on est ensemble et on se connait pas !
C'est fou des fois j'ai l'impression qu'on partage que le loyer et le stress quoi c'est tout.
Ok, tu sais quoi, on va prendre des vacances, ça va nous faire du bien,
On va se détendre tout ça.
On pourrait aller à Rome tiens, un week end à Rome ça serait bien.
Mais putain, c'est quoi cette fixette sur l'Italie ?
Je sais pas j'ai dis l'Italie parce que de tout façon, on peut pas aller plus loin, car t'as peur de l'avion.
Bah escuse moi c'est hyper dangereux, comment ça marche !?
Ça vole !
Bah oui, bah explique-moi !
Ben qu'est-ce qui te prend ?
Nan mais c'est juste qu'on part en vacances ensemble, deux semaines,
que tout les deux, donc voilà, je pensais qu'il y avait un petit truc quoi.
Ben non y a rien non, y a pas de truc.
Non j'étais dispo, t'étais dispo... On part ensemble.
Je suis bien dispo oui...
En plus moi je pensais que t'étais...
Hé Pédés, ben ouais ils sont heureux !
Ah ben ouais, ils s'aiment hein c'est bien !
On baise ensemble, on dors ensemble, on mange ensemble, on joue à Overwatch ensemble !
On fait nos courses  ensemble, on est ensemble c'est tout !
Oui non mais, hé !
On est ensemble mais on est pas en couple,
c'est ça qui me gène moi, viens on continue à être,
un plan cul plus plus et on kiffe quoi.
Ensemble mais pas un couple.
Mais on va au Louvre, y a que les couples qui vont au Louvre !
Ou les familles !
Quand on aura un enfant je serais toujours un plan cul ?
Tu sais quand on saura si c'est un garçon ou une fille.
Je sais pas si je veux le garder, on a pas d'argent.
De quoi qu'est-ce que tu dis ?
Je me sens pas bien là.
C'est parce que tu respires pas assez, ça.
Faut que tu souffles.
Putain mais tu comprends rien à ce que je te dis ou quoi ?
Tu te calmes, c'est pas bon pour l'enfant !
Aller !
Non mais...
Aller, on tient,
Attends Nico j'en peux plus !
Oh plus de 40 ans !
Oui, tu te souviens au début, tu voulais rompre avec moi.
Mais c'est parce que ça allait trop vite.
J'avais peur.
Je regrette pas de t'avoir rapellé.
Si j'osais je te sauterais dessus.
Mais j'ai le dos en compote.
C'est pas grave, j'adore la compote.
Ah, demain je te ferais de la compote.
C'est con on a pas mal de points en communs tu vois.
Niveau de la bouffe,
Moi je suis sans gluten, toi t'es...
Moi je m'en fout.
Tu bouffes tout ouais...
Et le cinéma aussi.
Star Wars.
J'ai pas vu.
T'as pas vu, Star Wars, c'est ce que je disais... Moi non plus.
Et ouais...
Non...
Rien...